hey pal you okay shouldn't you be
working probably yeah but I just feel
like I look exactly the same every week
you know I see all these great video
game character changes and then there's
me in my same three stupid stripy
jumpers ain't no come on you you've
changed you've changed your hair you're
wearing a black dress and you started
bathing you noted yeah it's hard not to
yeah I just don't feel like it's a big
enough change you know maybe if I put on
my glasses okay is that any better I
feel pretty starting with Spyro the
Dragon even the scaly purple dragon king
of 90s platformers wasn't spared the
redesign rod with the launch of the
phenomenally successful Skylanders
franchise in 2011 something seemed a
little off about the mysterious dragons
mush however and it looked like the
spyro we all know unlocked had
repeatedly run into a wall remember
bomberman the cube bubble-headed hero
that clears past by setting off tiny
adorable bombs I'm pretty confident in
calling this one one of the worst
character redesigns of all time because
well just take a look in 2006 developer
hudson soft decided that bubble butt
just wasn't quite gritty enough for the
modern audience and surfer bomberman act
0 not only was the story given a grim
futuristic vibe but the new bomber man
and woman were turned into bad pieces of
iron man fan art now there's not been
many reasons to celebrate being a sonic
fan in recent years but sonic &
all-stars racing transformed alright
that's like one good game out of dozens
of terrible ones anyway when Sega
revealed the doomed sonic boom in
february2014 the internet was hardly
excited about new sonic feel more like
what the hell has happened to old sonic
while amy rose and tails got off
relatively scot free sonic was now
adorned with a spiffy new scarf and
looks like he went ten rounds on the
rack then we come to poor Knuckles the
Echidna was wrapped up in bandages was
packed on the pounds and grown a few
feet what happened did he dabble in
steroids as he had some work done by the
way the fan reaction was about
what you'd expect and finally we come to
Dante everyone's favorite half demon
demon hunting vigilante previously the
games were developed in Japan but in
2010 capcom announced that the latest
iteration and reboot DMC Devil May Cry
would be made in the West in Cambridge
actually anyway while old school Dante
was designed to fill creator Hideki
Kamiya vision of a cool and stylish man
reboot Dante was created from a Western
perspective unfortunately for fans that
translated as jerk which then translated
to terrible user scores on metacritic
and even death threats to Ninja Theory
staff I don't even think Dante was that
bad but knuckles yeah I don't really
care just don't ever put those glasses
on again mimi's glass no don't oh
actually that's really hard
three stripey jump almost where does it
feel to the Wonder video I'm about to
almost make out with myself hi Missy
James this is gonna be used against me
in the future so many times